soll ich mich auf unsere mappus drohte
ihnen ja definitiv
ja ob einem die folgen der eigenen es
und konsumgewohnheiten wurst sind oder
nicht sie sind längst zum politischen
akt geworden
auffallend viele jüngere menschen
beschäftigen sich derzeit intensiv mit
ökologischen und sozialen
ernährungsfragen etwa bei der
organisation slow food hughes ist essen
die neue politische jugendbewegung des
wohlgenährten westen so sieht heute ein
polit stammtisch ausland wird egal denn
food blog alle engagiert und jung doch
jung seien sei nicht alles laufe gut hat
nichts mit dem alter zu tun sondern eher
mit der inneren einstellungen
damit wird man vorwärts macht und nicht
sich verkopft der zusatz news steht also
für tatendrang teilnahmebedingungen
jeder und jeder bringt etwas zum essen
mit idealerweise bio und selber
zubereitet von der blutwurst focaccia
über das zitrone risotto
adonis muss verbindet sich so aufs
angenehmste mit aktivismus nur mit
gemüse sondern auch dahinter steht das
man dass man das rad bewegt
bewegung kommt durch austausch und sich
über die neuesten entwicklungen im
food-bereich auszutauschen ist für slow
food präsidentin laura shelly eines der
ziele der bewegung und programmatisch
auch die orte wo ihre treffen
stattfinden
dieses mal bietet der zero race laden in
zürich unterschlupf wo nahrungsmittel
ohne verpackungen verkauft werden
ein kleiner beitrag mit großer
signalwirkung dass sie über das produkt
über wie sie konsumiert einfluss könnte
und so wird es es um politische akt
früher gingen junge menschen auf die
straße um gegen atommüll zu
demonstrieren
heute kämpft man gegen food waste vom
sit in zum meeting ihn erstaunt das
nicht der philosoph hat lemke der sich
seit jahren mit der politischen
dimension des essens beschäftigt sieht
darin ein kollektives umdenken im umgang
mit essen vielleicht der anfang einer
ernährungs wende wie er es nennt in
einem ko garden im projekt bei hamburg
geht er mit gutem beispiel voran
wer kann soll gemüse selber an pflanzen
die stadt beim grossverteiler
einzukaufen und er beruft sich auf die
geschichte
oft sind es die nachfolgenden
generationen die mit alten gewohnheiten
brechen die jugend kann also ein
wichtiger motor für die ernährungs wende
sein
das ist sehr spannend an dem an dem
thema zu sehen dass das essen die jugend
politisiert dass sie tatsächlich auch
eine politische selbstwirksamkeit
erfahren
durch diese entscheidung was es sich wie
es sich viele ist es mir wert und so
also das glaube ich ist sehr
vielversprechend dass sie sehen sie
können etwas verändern
sie wollen veränderung die slow food
hughes aktivisten in zürich es geht um
konkrete maßnahmen wie die suche nach
freiwilligen für sogenanntes logo
projekte und es geht auch um nichts
geringeres als um die rettung der welt
[Musik]
essen hat einen riesigen einfluss auf
unsere um die konkrete food aktivismus
könnte die welt für die zukünftigen
generationen bewahren
klingt ehrenhaft nur schaffen es die
aktivisten das bewusstsein
hinauszutragen damit es nicht in ihrem
hippen und urbanen kreis stecken bleibt
sicher ist ohne die große masse passiert
gar nichts
harald lemke hebt in seiner arbeit die
verantwortung jedes einzelnen hervor wir
von unten sozusagen als konsumenten
masse wie entscheidend das ist glaube
ich zum einen eine weltformel die wir
brauchen
jeder von uns verkörpert die menschheit
und ich als menschheit entscheide mich
im bereich des essens permanent für eine
bestimmte entwicklung der menschheit die
wir alle verkörpern
so wird jede einzelne handlung bedeutend
und der morgendliche kaffee zu einem
politischen statement
nie war es einfacher
verantwortungsvoller ethisch und
politisch zu handeln als über das essen
eine erkenntnis die immer mehr menschen
teilen ja es geht auch darum dass wir
das kochen das do it yourself in der
küche als eine erstrebenswerte
politische praxis vermittelt bekommen
das ist wirklich das ist das ist
wirklich auch revolutionär weil was
liegt denn weiter weg von von der
revolution als eine küche irgendwelches
gemüse schnippeln
wie schön wenn die revolution dann auch
noch so gut schmeckt vielleicht kann
essen die welt nicht alleine retten aber
ohne essen geht es bestimmt auch nicht
man kann es natürlich auch